[Music]
in got cotton is submitted by hello -
Bart only [ __ ] is that about hope it was
worth that response a grandmother says
she was tricked into bringing her
grandson drugs in prison it's great you
could turn grandparents to do anything I
don't see how I was tricked - if I was
bringing drugs to Mike yeah easy huh Oh
Percy I don't know any better
I barely know if I'm Peter yeah she made
like a paper mache no with [ __ ]
cocaine and [ __ ] she's the one that made
it it's like she's like I didn't know I
swallowed these drugs in this balloon I
thought I was small on a balloon [ __ ]
old people have the perfect defense so
Sarah that was just a pyro
Sarah the grandma she went to go visit
her grandson in Memphis Tennessee and
when she went there she gave him a
Doritos bag and a guard saw the exchange
of the Doritos bag and that's when the
the guard came up to the prisoner and
said like hey let me let me see what's
in the bag and before he gave him the
bag he took something out and I gave it
to the guard so I'm like the garden was
like well let me see what a idiot what
the [ __ ] is that about that's the
dumbest thing I've ever heard of my life
yes of course takes the cocaine out
that's when you take what you do is the
trick is you take a nacho chip out and
put it in your pocket
oh he's like only see what's in your
pocket button you're like no chip
um what you want is fine you want a
pocket right oh yeah magic would be
great to that greatness yes if this was
the coke you you wrap that up under the
palm and if this was the nacho chip you
take that out and he put it into your
pocket and then he goes what's in your
pocket no cuts he did that with no cuts
by the way no cuz
yeah yeah so then the the guard like
they opened what it was because it was
something wrapped in black electrical
tape and that's not obvious yeah never
seen that before balloon what they saw
was a green leafy substance yellow pills
and white powder and then later on it
tested positive like a drug casserole
too pointy yeah 2.0 twenty-eight point
five grams of meth eleven point four
grams of marijuana forty bars of
prescriptions annex that's a lot of [ __ ]
one point seven grams of ecstasy and 1.1
grams of heroin dad this one wants to do
everything he was starting a little
pharmacy oh there was nothing in that
Doritos bag huh that's like the Avengers
of drugs all in one little ball I know
nacho so grandma brought over Doritos
bag mm-hmm was it sealed because that's
pretty dope I don't know but once she so
they arrested her for contraband charge
contraband charges and then so she told
the officers that she thought she was
just bringing a cell phone to her
grandson she didn't know that's just as
bad
that's just as bad she said I know she
looks cute
I know she looks like she can't hurt a
fly but this is her grandson this is her
grandson as a ringleader I know everyone
looks cute when they're old right but
have you seen that documentary about the
supplier for what's-his-name that the
the the narcos guy Escobar
yeah there's a female a part of the
Colombian cartel the Medellin Cartel and
she's like the boss lady and she looks
like a sweet little old grandma she'll
[ __ ] people up yeah she was pretty like
her stories like she got connected with
I guess like this this one dude in
Oakland and they started having like a
relationship
this guy's she's like a grandma pimp
like during visits but she would pay the
guards and they would just like [ __ ]
a janitor's closet and stuff and she
looks like that like a chunkier version
that she would [ __ ] prison guards and
they know like like this this young guy
that's like that started to court her
because he knows how to Toria she is and
then like she would supply him with a
connection and he became this big drug
dealer in Oakland and yeah
yeah I know I'm like dang but then she
looks like just this sweet little
Colombian lady you know who's Pablo's
biggest supplier the [ __ ] CIA what
come at me what what what G ogres no not
when the hell if she shook her head at
me and off-camera she said to you a
hundred percent agrees nation brothels
they ask sweet little old ladies that
are the mamasan and then you like oh you
think they're all [ __ ] sweet but they
used to be hookers themselves and then
they grew up and Darla's i'ma just Ron
so I'm saying that's what people are
like oh look at that oh that person
probably suck so much dick you have no
idea yep you don't know they probably
shot people you don't know oh no it did
something I'll be pissed dude because
they used to look young you don't
remember that
they just look innocent right now all
grandmas were [ __ ] at one point yep
Oh what all grand monsters let's all
look it up Geo look it up no it's fact
if you want to look it up yeah just
because they look like a wrinkled old
raisin doesn't mean that they haven't
been around up my luck my grandma was
not a [ __ ] don't you dare say that how
much everything how can you prove it
because how can you prove that your
grandma's house what she has a diary oh
okay grandma's diary
they all have Diaries cliff and I were
playing basketball and there's this like
really old dude like clearly shooting
and he was absolutely terrible for a
second I thought he was blind
wait the way he was shooting and so I
probably let us shoot around the court
too amen you might if we should run with
you he goes well I am practicing aren't
I and I'm like oh yeah well people are
me okay so I sat back down c41 old guy
say I was like and then we just kind of
sat there and then we kind of looked
around and then you said one more thing
he goes well we all gotta practice
and I'm like why good for the NBA
combine
i sat there then I got even more
offended so he won up this [ __ ] because
afterwards like you know like the Tesla
I'm driving it up a ship and then he
comes up to us but he called me and he
goes right up to Khalif he goes well
how'd you get that car cuz he thought he
was a basketball player and I was like
first of all I didn't even a small
player like what the [ __ ] you thought he
bite you were his driver
yeah highly offended slightly offended
thank you instead of being a treating as
a pejorative
he literally as I'm talking to him he
won't even make eye contact he's just
talking to Khalif because I think he
just made an NBA player that's fine I
thought you [ __ ] dick we were playing
tennis at the park and then these senior
citizens they were like the tennis
bullies because I guess they have they
rent the park or they rent the tennis
courts at a certain time but no one
knows this but they expect everyone to
know so they come and they start yelling
at people
[ __ ] swinging their rackets and
they're like it's at this time it's
reserved time and then he's like [ __ ]
mean and I'm like Dan do these seniors
are like thugs dude the old lady lose my
building who is is the meanest person I
think I've ever met do I have one of
those where she doesn't even like look
at you or if she does she like layers of
cheese she goes by you in the hallway
damn but if you like you do your laundry
and then you took like even one minute
to get your laundry after it was done
she's like you're tected forever see
[ __ ] no she's so bored and old like I'm
just like I can't wait till you die I'll
be so happy when you die yep when I'm in
low light I'll go buy a cigar when she
died my good childbirth your that Conroy
I used to run out of a capacity when I
first moved here yeah so when I lived
there there was this person beneath that
every time we would just like chill or
just anything right she's just our
[ __ ] hitting the time yeah and I got
[ __ ] so fed up one day I was like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] so I went
down bait on a door she opens the door
turns out she was blind and I was like
hi I'm your neighbor I've ever just
there but you you can just let me go
princely
you tell she's fine instantly she had
the [ __ ] glasses in the hole stick
this to get to the door the Yanks I feel
terrible when she was on her way to the
door did you hear crash like does she
walk around in karate sparring gear like
in her house my thing is like I'm
guessing cuz she's blind her senses must
be hiding this [ __ ] she hears
everything you [ __ ] superhero you
know do you're just a bunch of glassware
breaking and then you're like hey what
are you doing she's like I wonder people
become grumpy or they've been a [ __ ]
and then it just gets crazier really I
feel like they become grumpy
well do they get the list [ __ ] they get
like I don't I hadn't resting grumpy
though yeah I might just just grumpy
like resting face grumpy I don't know
look I'm not here to like ruin somebody
else's life yeah I mean I'm scrum people
myself right no it's funny because that
maybe remind I'm talking about she's
like the HOA [ __ ] no president I don't
think she's the president but she's like
something up there so she's always held
vigilant of everything that happens and
so when we first moved there I had a we
had a whole bunch of boxes in a lot of
trash so I moved the dumpster over to
her our places okay and she was just she
came out like you me it was like if I
killed her cat or something like how
dare you what do you think you are you
know a literal thing like not even that
FAR's
you fee know what you're gonna move it
back right because we have like stairs
to go down to the garage I just moved it
neither the stairs of my garage so they
could just be easier just throw how did
she know that you moved
because it was because I didn't I didn't
do it why'd you put the [ __ ] in here
yeah why'd you move it lady I don't know
I didn't move it no and then so from
then on I was like man he's a [ __ ] cuz
every time we could always hear her -
when she gets home with her husband
they're just bickering at each other I'm
like man that poor man anytime there's a
complaint like we get a like a email
from the office lady or whatever we know
it's the old lady like like telling the
whole building something like if
somebody had their music on somebody
think it's always the old lady when
you're when you're a [ __ ] H away
person starts arguing you should put in
a complaint to her I'd say like my
neighborhood always is always yelling at
her husband just plug it just send it
right over there you go are you [ __ ]
cut back when she dies I'm taking all
you out to dinner
somewhere real nice oh yeah
$30,000 there's a cake with her face up
just a buy her a dog man I think that
would chill him out I will say though
for all this stuff like like a couple
couple months ago I noticed that she was
bald Olson I was like oh [ __ ] so maybe
cancer is getting here now I was like I
hope that she wins obviously you want to
say the right thing the nice thing
[Music]
[Music]